tonalité bonne encore pour cette
première fête de l'europe mais les
clowns et 8 secondes et peut passer un
seul outil s'avère le claquer logique
sioniste l'acte vous trouverez en fait
en face de deux mauvaises solutions qui
est que les serbes ont pallié
effectivement la partie michel bas mais
les croates ont un petit peu étendu leur
territoire
là on est optimiste et on réfléchit à
l'europe de deux marocains jouent à 16
commence avant que je vois sans
défaillir le chemin humaine n'est pas
plat mais pas l'europe le temps d'y
penser
aujourd'hui l'europe sargos étrangers
plus
aden - par exemple le drapeau du canada
le concours financier hiver edouard
balladur a envoyé un message aux
participants et son mini sonore
s'affairaient dans la masure débarraser
faire le polonais l'irak a cité de
l'avenir de l'europe de l'est et de
l'aide de la communauté à 13h l'orage
éclate
l'europe se replie sous sa tente petit
pour les uns un peu court
si je vous dis que ça ressemble un peu à
une fête de l'humanité bon chic bon
genre
c'est parce que
alors que pas comparer le tour d'un
déjeuner très consensuel et le soleil
est revenu
l'optimisme ou ci est mal vu si on
devait pour faire la fête
attendre qu'il y ait plus de souffrance
dans le monde n'y aurait jamais eu de
fait depuis que l'homme est sur la terre
elle n'est pas sûre que les gens font la
fête et le pôle solution politique
commençait à la fac à la fois y avait
pas d âge là c'est la politique connaît
tous les pays européens
la france
berry
oui
en fin de journée l'angleterre une petit
se faire sauver la fête sexuelles avec
envie et les fils du désert groupe
d'inspiration cents
certains auraient bloqué pratiqué la
saisie